Một quà mềm muốn thằng chiến năm 2019, thông tin từ công an thành của Hanoi,
đơn vị đã tạm sữa hình sự lối tự lình văn lâm, sinh năm 2019,
từ chú tại Sà Anh, Tình Phú Thọ, đề điều tra về hình vì rất người.
Chứ đó, bao khoảng chiến dở 2 phút mềm bà thằng chiến năm 2019,
tại gần cầu truyv at điểm tục thu lập sân, sát phu xuyên, Hanoi,
sế ra vụ tên an giá thông sữa xe bồn chở biết tông và xe máy định.
Hầu quà, nước xin, sinh năm 2019, đều khiến xe máy định bị thương,
đều biết cấp cứu tại bình Việt bệnh mai, sau đó từ văn.
Sau khi sế ra sử việc tại Sà bồn là điên văn lâm đã bỏ chủnh hỏi hệ chương.
Cơ quan kể rất điều tra công an thành phố, phòng cảnh xác xa thông đáp với hợp các đình vị trích năm,
công an sát phu xuyên tổ chức khám nghiệp hệ chương, tính hình các vị pháp đều tra,
làm só vụ việc theo quy định. Đến khoảng mi chính dở cùng ai, đối tượng điên văn lâm đã đi công an sát phu xuyên đầu tụ.
Tại các khoảng công an, lông đã thử những hành vi cố ý tiếp tục đu khiến xe ô tổ kéo lên nạn nhân trên đường,
sau khi và trả, rất đến thương viết nạn rồi tử văn.
Một biết là đi trên nạn nhân tử văn và lòng đi tụ sẽ không phải loa điên vụ tình trên nạn nhân.
Cái quà sẽ nghĩa đối với lâm không có nùng độ cùng trong hơi tử vãng tính với máy.
Hành vi thì phạm của lòng hết sức tả nhiễn, vô nhìn đạo với độ cơ đe hình.
Căn cứu và tệ lựa thu thập được, ngày 1 tháng 7 năm 2019,
các khoảng cạnh rất đều trạm công an thành của hành uổi đã ra quy định tạm sức hình sự đing văn lâm để đều trạm về hành viết nguyên.